everybody it's gary vaynerchuck
garyvaynerchuk.com as you can see I'm in
my Wine Library TV mode here about to
get ready yes very much
go Saints um drawing lines in the sand
you know uh I just did a Wine Library TV
with with a with a guest I thought was
very interesting he talked about
winemaking style where he feels like you
should react to the vintage got me
thinking about a couple meetings I've
had in the last couple days where
clients have said to me that's not our
customer or that's not what our
customers want and and different things
that I've seen from other brands and
other companies and it just becomes a
massive theme to me I am down right I
don't know Mom gonna get up because I'm
so downright stunned if the lowest of my
mind blows my mind that in 2010 where
the consumer has such a massive voice
that companies still feel that they have
the option of drawing lines in the sand
saying what their customers think or how
they feel and they're basing that on
reports that they get six months to a
year later about you know usually
reports that are built to say what they
want I think we clearly are now living
in a world where businesses have no
option but to react to what the pulse of
the consumer is now this second because
you understand what search.twitter.com
and what facebook status updates and
what blog posts and what you know
comments on other people's blog posts
have created is a now society and if
you're a brand or a business and you're
drawing lines in the sand assumptions of
what your consumer is or what your
consumer wants and you're not backing
that up with real-time data well then
you're making a huge mistake and you're
not clearly seeing where this new world
is heading and so what I guess my hope
is with this video is because I know a
lot of brand managers watch this I know
a lot of people that are making
decisions watch this and very flattered
for that thank you is that if you don't
react to what's going on this second
then you're behind the curve it has
never been fast
it has never been faster than it is
right now and technology's real push has
changed every rule in traditional
marketing and branding and if you don't
live in this new world right this second
not it's coming or if we'll adjust when
it matters right this second may be
looking for a new job real quick